qu'est ce qui se passe qui êtes-vous
je suis ton mari ben on est marié depuis
14 ans tuvalu un accident et tu te
souviens plus des choses quelque chose
tout je l'étais je suis le docteur match
ça ne vous dira rien mais ne vous
inquiétez pas nous faisons un travail
sur votre mémoire reconnaître que ce
n'est pas une relation docteur patients
ordinaires je vous vois sans que votre
mari de sache je veux que vous teniez un
journal visuel pour ne pas perdre vos
souvenirs jeunes at-il christine coget
de relief il ya des jours où tu dois
sûrement en avoir assez de vivre ça
parfois quand la vérité fait mal et
compliqué les pas toujours la force
vous étiez nu iv du sort acceptez-vous
je commence à me rappeler certaines
choses
est ce que ta maison il dit qu'il veut
te protéger l'union faisait pas
confiance
lavez ne tourne pas qu'autour de toi
je veux que vous vous sentiez bien
non